everybody's gary vaynerchuk caravan trip
com um so a lot of people are always
asking me well step by step you talk
about doing what you love right and you
talk about passion and you talk about
you know monetizing talking about ROI
you down with me yeah you know I took
about a lot of stuff and a lot of its in
general um I think I get more specific
than a lot of people it's what I pride
myself that's why I do so much QA at
conferences but I thought I'd you
something really neat my you like that
meat today I'm gonna give you an example
of a show that has run through my head
I'm not gonna do this show so you're
more than welcome to do this and do it
on your own and I hope you make a
gazillion dollars I'm gonna do a show
and break down every element about the
show and how you turn it into a business
this should be really neat I'm really
excited about this i don't even know
what's about to happen it's been an idea
of running through a mine my show is
going to be this it's gonna be called
the baseball card our I thought of this
even you can come in ian's prepping Wine
Library TV my idea is you would call it
the baseball card show right we're to
baseball card our and what you would do
is five days a week you would open up an
old school pack of cards why I like this
idea number one I think the investment
would be very minimal here's why I think
that if you got about 10 to 15 to 25
episodes in that you'd be able to get
sponsors fans would send you in packs
and you could buy so many cheap packs on
ebay this day so that's what I was
thinking about you can go on and buy box
of cards for four or five bucks you know
that gives you 24 packs that's 24 shows
four weeks right for ten fifteen dollar
investment of course you want a little
variety but you could be just one pack
but what's really neat is I think
quickly you would have fans sending
impacts my fans sent me in these packs
which I have a couple more of the NP you
do me favor grab some of the boxes that
i have up back there behind the couch so
a fancy mean that's how i started doing
it on the show the idea that showed me
the baseball card hours you'd open up a
pack of cards each day of course not
knowing so the suspense factor for the
show i think would be very cool thanks
see the best man so you see I had a fan
send me some fleer past skybox for
basketball 91 upper deck which I in
front of me and some for for sport pack
palmas up from Washington this is the
package you sent a great guy Mike
right Mike's first name anyway anyway
you open a package day and yet you can
see one fan set me up in a situation
where I've got probably two months worth
of shows you open up the pack and you
talk about the players that are in the
pack you get a lot of old school people
that are into this is a lot of kids in
my age group works kids you know 31 32
probably them sweet spot is 25 to 35
year old males great demo to advertise
against if you start getting a following
much more broad than wine is than what
i'm doing cuz this is sports really for
example like hey everybody this is gary
vaynerchuk for the baseball card out now
again on animated you don't have to be
you could be hey everybody Tom Stevens
again here for the baseball card our and
today we're gonna be opening a pack of
1991 to protect maybe do a little
homework you say you know 1991 upper
deck was the second third year for upper
deck they start in 1989 they were a
company that revolutionized the baseball
card industry because they were the
first people to come out with packs that
were over two dollars a pack or dollar
pack our members probably like two bucks
you do some homework right you do some
back-end which one economy in serum
watch this as I do this show seem to
think of it anyway so you do a little
bit it's kind of gonna be weird though
cuz I'm not really gonna do the show so
I'm doing it this style where I'm
breaking it down but everybody's scared
he may be shook end this day on low
Michigan everybody's Gary better chicken
today we are doing on the baseball card
our a pack of 1991 upper deck baseball
cards and you know I'll protect hit the
scene hard in 1989 um came out of
nowhere a company high quality high
glossy we never seen anything like that
before you know Dom was clear and tops
were pretty much dominating the day here
came this upstart upper deck they were
very expensive by the pack it was the
first time we sort of seen the kids
being eliminated from the game no gum in
self ain't got very expensive 34 bucks a
pack and this is the 1991 upper deck set
now again you can go into the top cards
from this set or blah blah blah right
hopefully we'll get one of them and we
could say is something like you know and
if i get to sandy alomar rookie card
that's five dollars i will absolutely
send it to the first person that leaves
sandy Alomar batting average in 99 sick
it gives you a lot of room to do a lot
of cool you don't give aways um and then
again you'd go right into it yeah but
awesome camry i'm like mot you don't
even need a camera man because you can
have it still like this but if you did
or not have somebody about here we go
let's get into it right off the bat this
was a big one of the big cards you can
actually get
I inversion to a Nolan Ryan baseball
heroes card 16 of 18 I know that they
were and what's really cool you can go
into some like this he goes collect all
my Nolan Ryan baseball set cards
randomly inserted in packs find one of
the 2500 personally autographed Nolan
Ryan cards now imagine right now I
openness end of this was one of them and
again it probably isn't worth that much
but that would have been crazy so you
always have the beauty of doing a
baseball card show or a card show is you
always have a suspense angle which i
think is great for television anyway I'd
be like all right we got one of these I
remember these are like two three four
or five bucks each when I first hit the
scene and then you go into it and what's
great about doing the sports card show
is you can go into sports in general to
geoff gray you know and then you could
say something like you know from the Red
Sox you say you know what I don't
remember Jeff grade but you know is this
a great example of why the Red Sox are
now winning World Series with Beckett
and daisuke and Lester you can turn into
cop you know there's always always
current events and sports so for me this
would be great because I can talk about
the red sox playoff run right now with
this first card and that's content you
know it's always a Content opportunity
with doing I'm sports card i go on then
i go gym needling her again a dodger and
now I probably say something funny like
oh my god are we gonna have a Philly
necks and an array and I'm like oh wait
no we can't have a right because the
Rays weren't in baseball yet so like
it's always giving you content
opportunities now you go into Rafael
Palmeiro right into the steroids issue
hey Rafi you look pretty skinny there
buddy and you can look look at it and
say and then you get the hologram card
now I've been doing my number Kimmy we
had three straight days of Braves
Holograms it's nice to see an ace
hologram and then you could talk about
Willie McGee how he look like an alien
maybe you can look into some of his
stats I said look at Willie McGee you
know in 1987 for the Cardinals he batted
you know 285 I always thought up in more
of a 300 hitter you can get into that
you know it's always gonna be things
like there's always gonna be a Chris no
bus you know who you have nothing to say
you could say it's the former expose
then they have sweet logo you can maybe
talk about you know something on the
back of his card Tom Bolton another bum
pitcher for the Red Sox you get into
Greg brealey and again you go through
the motions you talk about the Braves
Mitch Webster I mean miss you Webster
you tell a personal story how many
people out there are fans of Cleveland
you talk about some stats maybe can get
at the fact that the juice ball era or
the steroid era that we're going through
now
numbers were much smaller you get into
Robby Thompson talk about how good of a
shortstop he really was for those giant
teams you know then you get into Bill
Doran you have no idea but I could say
like Ian Dorrans here with me right now
is bill related to you know all right
dan Petry I remember him Ron Kovic the
catcher and Derek linquist and again the
mo of the cards is there's always
content I kind of skimmed through
because I've been a long video ready but
you could always get into it you can
always get it into the factors of what's
going on in sports you know if you did a
basketball pack you know the NBA's just
about the start you know hey everybody
today and here's what's neat now let's
get into the business part of it one
there's no doubt my mind that tops and
the other sports card companies and
steiner sports and people like this are
definitely people you could hit up after
you have a little critical mass if you
pump out about 40 50 shows and you're in
a place where you've got a couple
hundred to a couple thousand viewers
this is definitely something you can
email to people say hey I've got the
show I've got good intern act
interaction because you've got all these
contests and stuff I think you should
look at it and all of a sudden your show
starts like this hey everybody's Gary
Vaynerchuk for the baseball card out a
sports car tower and this show is
brought to you by snyder sports tire
sports let's link them up and again now
you got a fifty-dollar 100 dollar per
episode sponsored by the way for such
spite sign Steiner Steiner Rick Steiner
Steiner sports or tops or upper deck or
whatever's left in the baseball card
business this would be a tremendous
thing for them to advertise in because
we don't have tremendous roi because
everybody that's watching is watching
somebody open a pack of cards that is
perfect demo understand so anyway you
know everybody's Gary mansion from this
sports car down or brought to you by
steiner sports steiner sports get into
the game alright today we're opening
skybox 94 95 just like upper deck skybox
came on the scene in 92 the shack rookie
card one hundred dollars they came with
premium packs they were the real big
scene we only had hoops really doing
anything before that let's open his pack
let's see what's going on and we've got
Vincent ask you he's about all John
Starks and right away I would go
ironically in this room in like mot show
it let's bring up the camera pick it up
yeah you know what the move is all real
so authentic baby didn't have to move I
would probably go like you know if I had
a camera man but if I didn't I'd
probably pick it up and be like that is
the greatest moment in John Starks
career as you can see I've got a John
start poster when he dunks on all the
I was at the game anyway so I go back
and I cook oh I got a rookie card now
there's so many other cool things you
can do for example ebay has an affiliate
program right a bring one of these cards
after you're done taping let's say the
Ron how not run out go on Howard rookie
card was still worth two bucks because I
know cards are really depreciate in
value but let's say was or if I got a
Nolan Ryan signed it might not be worth
500 like used to be but even if its
twenty bucks I could in theory on this
show just like I do with wine library TV
have the wines link below at the end of
show saying and if you want any of these
cards you know we're not gonna sound
because we love them but you can
definitely get these on ebay and then
you could have the link with your
affiliate link to the ebay auction and
you can sell maybe 20 or 30 bucks a day
in cards maybe even two bucks but it all
adds up it's all cash flow revenue you
go through he goes in Horace Grant how
much you hated him you can go back to
the fact that he was in that picture
kind of cool that he can maybe even make
like John Starks dunk over horse grant
you know like crush um cuz you hated the
Bulls with all your passion and you get
into kevin johnson who's running for
mayor now and you just go through Reggie
Miller another guy you know just not a
good guy as a Knicks fan so a lot of
angles and a lot of money to be made
with the affiliate programs to ebay the
sponsorship to the show your fan base is
probably gonna send you the packs but
even if they wouldn't after a while you
can always buy them on ebay for low cost
a lot of fun and for anybody that loved
cards growing up or is really into
sports this is what I talked about this
is what exactly i talked about 49 26
year old lawyer you come home you set up
a camera and you do this for two hours
you're having a good time maybe have
some buddies over you talk about stuff
you talk about sports could lead to
writing a sports article and local paper
could lead to much bigger things like
being on Conan or Ellen like me you know
what i mean so opportunist and there's a
business plan with the whole affiliate
links whether it's too you know amazon
might be some cards or some other sites
out there probably have affiliate links
i love the ebay angle because I gets fun
maybe get your fans been against each
other I just think there's so much to do
when you put passion and ideas and
business together and this is the
perfect business for a guy my age that
grew up with this stuff it'd be a lot I
mean I would do this I mean I would
really put together a show it could be
so much fun that's example that's it get
out of here